a tilt of the head a verbal cue
and specific facial expressions are just
a few of the ticks we see
certain actors display sometimes actors
just can't help it when their quirks and
mannerisms slip into their roles
they carry specific traits from roll to
roll and once you spot them
it's impossible to unsee or unhear let's
see which actors have noticeable traits
that pop up
in their roles wow right
if you're a fan of friends this is going
to change the way you view
jennifer aniston's character rachel
throughout the show
aniston will start a sentence by
coughing and clearing her throat
it's subtle but once you notice it it's
impossible to not hear it every time
it happens and it happens a lot
um no you do realize
let me just now when you watch friends
you're gonna notice this verbal cue
every single time
i don't know i don't know how i feel
steve carell is known for his comedic
bits and timing
but one signature trait of his stands
out he makes a lot of
weird noises from the office to
anchorman to get smart and many more
corel can't seem to help making an
allotment of strange noises
when you catch him doing this it
definitely feels more like steve himself
than the character he is playing
that being said there are a lot of great
unique characters with this quirky
elizabeth olsen's wanda maximoff is one
badass superhero
who can deliver an incredibly
intimidating stare but
she also delivers a cute quirky facial
expression
keep an eye out and it won't take long
to discover the avenger scrunching up
her nose
we see her do this in captain america
civil war and several times throughout
wandavision
this is the side of the avenger you
would want to see if you ever met
because being on the other end of her
cold stare would not end well for you
oh it's such a strange sensation it's
kind of fluttery
there are too many movies to name when
it comes to the amount of times owen
wilson has
uttered this exclamatory word wilson
can't help but murmur
this word in every role he plays he has
done it so many times
that you can spot variations in the way
he says it from loudon in your face
to quietly whispering it to himself wow
wow wow wow
this has become a staple of wilson's
characters and you can almost guarantee
a wow
in every movie he is in oh wow thank you
for that
if you're a fan of twilight you may want
to look away kristen stewart has a very
noticeable habit in these films
she exhales nervously
she does this throughout the entire
twilight series as her character bella
swan
she can also be heard doing this in her
other movies as well
such as adventureland and once you hear
her do this back to back to back
you realize how consistent it is
she seems to be nervous in a lot of her
movies
here's something interesting about
kaylee cuoco from the big bang theory
she loves to purse her lips we see this
throughout
the big bang theory whether she's
annoyed or telling a joke or just going
about her day
we also see cuoco pursing her lips in
other roles such as in the flight
attendant and we even see her doing this
in real life
interviews wherever cuoco goes this
trait follows
what's up buttercup goldblum has one of
the most
unique ways of delivering his lines he
doesn't read them straight through like
most would instead he has a stammer
filled with
us and um's that make his characters
take more time than normal to deliver
lines
we see goldblum with this stammer in
multiple roles
from dr ian malcolm to the grandmaster
in thor ragnarok actually but uh
but life uh finds a way
uh the the uh uh
the ass place aspect i call
contender at this point it would be
weird if goldblum didn't stammer his way
through his lines
there's another example ben stiller is a
very emotive actor
and we noticed one recurring gesture he
does throughout his movies
whenever stiller's character has a line
that includes the word a little
he does the same hand motion to
emphasize his point
we see this in night at the museum
duplex meet the fockers little [ __ ]
and more
once you pick up on it it's something
you'll notice across his characters
and it just made me feel little i felt
like a little man who didn't like flan
keanu reeves is one of the most beloved
actors right now
which means we also love all of his
quirks
including his propensity to say whoa in
every movie he is in much like owen
wilson's wow
the woe seems to be a catch-all word
reeves uses to express his surprise
in bill and ted's excellent adventure
in the night before and in the matrix
we say the same thing when we see you
keanu
if you watch a matthew mcconaughey movie
odds are you'll hear his character say
all right multiple times all right
all right all right it's something that
mcconaughey says in multiple roles of
his
we hear it in dazed and confused glory
days
and the wedding planner just to name a
few it's a word that has become
synonymous with mcconaughey's characters
because of how
often he says it all right all right
all right all right all right you can
watch any george clooney film
and chances are you'll catch him tilting
his head it's something he does in
practically every role he plays
as it just comes naturally to him there
are actually
so many examples of this that it would
take several minutes to show them all
clooney is one of the most charming
actors in hollywood
and his signature head tilt is a reason
for that we're sure we'll keep seeing
this as long as clooney keeps acting
harrison ford likes to make his point in
movies
pun intended whenever he's lecturing
someone or telling them something
important he emphasizes it with a point
of the finger
it's a rather aggressive and in your
face gesture that crops up in multiple
different types of characters he plays
as han solo in star wars or as the
titular indiana jones
ford makes sure you are paying attention
to what he has to say
it's over enough if you watch john
bernthal and the walking dead
you'll notice that he likes to rub his
head a lot
he does this whenever he's anxious in
two seasons as shane
he rubs his head roughly 25 times it's a
tick that will catch your eye
and you won't be able to stop looking
for it once you find it
because batman v superman
you went into the theater expecting to
see an epic showdown
between lex luthor and superman but
before you knew it
you were more focused on jesse
eisenberg's odd tics
eisenberg does this throughout the
entire movie
and it was a very distracting tick to
say the least
we'll have to wait and see if this comes
back the next time eisenberg plays lex
luthor
if he ever gets the chance to play the
character again
no no no ma'am you may be familiar with
the phrase
my man but did you know its popularity
comes from denzel washington's liberal
use of the phrase
washington uttered the phrase seven
times in american gangster
and the line has since become associated
with him
my man my man
my man my man snl even had a sketch that
included the phrase
making sure to note that it was the
denzel washington version
my man but like like the way denzel
washington says it
we must admit no one says it better than
him
it's fun to watch such talented
individuals accidentally bring some of
their personal traits into their roles
we wonder if we will continue to see
these quirks and mannerisms in future
roles these actors portray
who do you think had the most noticeable
tick let us know